it seemed like you and cam had a nice
connection going on today at practice
what's the process been like with cam
just getting to know him on and off the
field
[Music]
i think uh it's it's been that we're
we're still just trying to get to know
each other um
you know just like i am with all my new
teammates
um but specifically with you know a guy
that you know distributes the football
um
you know just kind of getting to know
each other as
people on the field off the field and um
you know trying to build a rapport um
that's what i'm doing also with with hoy
and stid but those guys have been around
so it's been a
you know it's been one of those things
where i gotta i gotta catch uh catch up
with cam
julian edelman super bowl 53 mvp when
tom brady was the quarterback now
cam newton hoy is brian hoyer stid as
jared stidham they had been splitting
the reps up chris but with jared
stidham's injury that's going to put him
out of action for a while cam newton
getting more and more of the reps
quarterbacks coach jed fish is on this
morning weei raving about cam newton's
work ethic and how quickly he's picking
up the offense it feels like newton is
doing what they were trying to cajole
him into doing yeah which is stepping up
and taking over yeah no doubt about it
and i mean just by the current events of
what we're hearing this weekend and
things i mean i think you could put a
nail in the uh old quarterback
competition in there in new england you
know jared stidham he hasn't played in
the nfl yet now this was a big offseason
for him that got cut short you know now
training camp he's dealing with a leg
injury and of course he's battling a guy
that's super talented motivated been an
nfl mvp and was very close to winning
the super bowl so yeah i would think
it's in the bag right now cam newton's a
starting quarterback that's over with
done with and mike to echo what you're
saying that's just the number one thing
i hear from there or anybody in new
england you know
not that they give information out but
they love the energy
and just the charisma that cam brings to
the locker room on the field every day
he loves football i mean that shows
through we know that and i think it's
rubbing off on this patriots team and
he's you know kind of creating a little
uh leadership niche for himself there in
new england already
and the way that everything unfolded
where he had to spend those weeks and
months wondering when and afl have
another chance in the nfl to have that
happen the way it did to kind of get him
in the right mindset to embrace football
to love everything about it you know
after nine years the same thing every
year and you've had the injuries the
past two years it's very easy to become
disenchanted and disillusioned and
disheartened and now it's all new it's
all fresh with a new team a team that's
got six banners a team that has the
pieces in place has the coaching staff
and
i look cam newton will never articulate
this
but
it it doesn't take a genius
to look at tom brady
look at cam newton
and say
if they did what they did with tom brady
my god what could they do in new england
with cam newton well i think that's a
fair thing to ask no doubt about that i
mean we know cam newton's physical raw
ability of course is greater than tom
brady now tom brady's greatness was the
fact that he's got a great arm he's a
great decision maker he's just as clutch
and cool and calm and tough situations
as you've ever seen and he could you
know mentally handle the gymnastics of
that
very complicated new england offense and
you know the fact that it's changes so
much on a week-to-week basis that's the
greatness of brady now this is where to
me the injury to stood them a little bit
as a blessing in disguise because of
kind of like what you're saying here it
kind of ends all the distraction the
noise about this julian edelman is not
going to have to hear about this anymore
no we know brian hoyer is not starting
over cam newton that's not happening so
now they're going to be able to start
just formulating the team and the
offense around cam newton with this
being done and i think that's going to
make you know empower the team and
empower the coaches a little bit to not
have to worry so much about ooh let's be
fair to jared siddom we're still letting
these guy compete do all that i think
now they can kind of go into all right
cam's our guy we got a regular season
game here in two or three weeks let's
start you know slowly
doctoring up plays in an offense that
fit him and can make us a better
football team going here in the season
and uh from that aspect i think it was
it was a blessing in disguise for the
pats
i still think the overriding challenge
is to get cam newton to a point where if
things are not going their way or his
way on a given day yeah he does not
throw in the towel with that demeanor
that dejection we've seen in the past
the high highs the low lows tom brady
thrived on the adversity i mean this is
the guy who erased the 28 to three third
quarter deficit in super bowl 51. i
think part of what they're trying to do
is get him to realize that even a bad
day while playing football is still a
pretty damn good day so keep at it don't
give up that's right keep pushing and if
he does that and if it and all it takes
is one time for the dam to break one of
those days where if he feels like he did
in the past where we're just getting our
butts kicked today it's not working and
he keeps plugging and it works yes that
can fix it forever fix it forever keep
plugging man i didn't play good but i'm
just going to continue to be positive
and be a leader and try to execute the
game plan oh man here we are the last
drive of the game whoa i made two or
three plays man it was ugly today but i
stayed in there mentally to what you're
talking about and look we won the
football game you know there's been a
lot of games like that with brady
through the years you know we go through
the game and oh man new england doesn't
have it today and all of a sudden the
last two drives of the game because
brady's brady and he stayed mentally in
it and positive he puts two drives
together and you go oh my gosh i cannot
believe they won this freaking game they
couldn't move the ball for three and a
half quarters then he makes two drives
like that you know the stats looks kinda
good after those two drives to where you
go oh it wasn't that bad of a day but
they win a football game and you're
right that's a testament to brady and
it's a lot as the course the culture
there in new england it is always on to
cincinnati it's always on to the next
thing on to the next thing beat date
deal be detailed let's get better on to
the next thing on to the next thing
let's not pout about the last thing or
anything like that and they will beat
that into your brain there like no other
place and it will become part of you
because it's just the way the coaches
and everybody in that building acts uh
and i would be shocked if he kind of
doesn't adopt it as well
you've said it before
something about walking through those
doors the first time something about
understanding that you either adjust to
the way they do things or you have no
chance right and
you know i i think that the belief is
cam newton's got it in him to be molded
in the way that the patriots mold their
guys you take the physical ability you
make him into that guy with that mindset
that tom brady had and it's look it's
going to take a while to get him even
close to the point where tom brady was
from the standpoint of processing
information just because brady did it
for 20 years sure but but i i feel like
they've taken that basic lump of clay
that is that tremendous talent and
they're beginning the process of making
him into a guy
who embraces and lives the patriot way
and that is scary for everything
everyone else if that works if they pull
this off
it's going to be scary for anyone they
play because uh if he can
play the way brady did and have that
focus and not get down and not get too
up either just keep plugging and keep
going and call the plays and listen to
what they do and take the coaching and
develop and grow and grow
it's it's you know they i saw the odds
for him
over the weekend for mvp they're
ridiculously long but they've got it was
a hundred to one now it's down to 30 to
one people are realizing there's a
chance this is going to work and it's
going to work very well in new england
for cam news yeah you know again i think
it's a an offensive line that's a little
bit better than what what it played last
year you know
some guys had some down years and a
little injured and banged up that way
but i look at that you know along with
some young
talent at the receiver position that you
think okay they can contribute to the
team this year and then of course you
know more to what you're saying i think
mike is they're going to build a way in
which they attack that is going to be
special around cam noon and it's going
to fit him and yeah it's not going to be
the exact tom brady offense no it will
not you know there's going to be
different aspects and a different look
to this but i think between that you
know the way the team is built the
defense being really good and giving
them lots of opportunities on offense to
get the ball back and make things happen
that way
i do i think new england's got enough
there to where i look at it and go oh i
would be shocked if they're not clicking
by week four or five and we start to go
damn cam newton this offense josh
mcdaniels they got it rolling what a
great formula they can run it throw it
play action pass do whatever they want
and then they sign earl thomas at some
point over the next couple of weeks and
say man we should have seen that coming
all along i mean they lost they lost
patrick chung to opt out even though
patrick chung's their strong safety
they'd find a way to make it work i mean
if you know that's the thing
we you can never rule the patriots out
for anyone they signed antonio brown
last year it didn't work that's not
going to keep bill belichick from trying
again when you have the six super bowl
championships you have a big old pile of
equity where you can take those chances
they took the chance with a b didn't
work taking the chance with cam newton
looks like it's going to work
and and it won't shock me it would
that's the ultimate because there's
something between the ravens and the
patriots
it's it's they're not the same division
but there's something like there's some
heat there there's some heat there and
if they can harness that whatever earl
thomas is thinking on his way out of
baltimore and get him in a bargain
basement contract and let baltimore pay
the balance if that's what ends up
happening i'm not going to be surprised
we've been down this road so many times
where we say oh the patriots aren't
going to mess with that guy and then
they do and we're like oh we should have
known this all along so i'm just
throwing it out there for possible
consideration as the
uh
preseason there isn't a preseason as
training camp continues to go forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports